what's up from family or should I say
fromalee we have a brand new episode of
from with all the corpse stabbing action
you could dream of in this video we'll
be taking a look at all the new Clues
theories and Mysteries the show has to
offer and as always I've left timestamps
below to all the topics I'll be covering
the sun's about to go down so follow me
at the end of last episode we learned
that Fatima might be pregnant with
Alice's baby something that is now
confirmed but according to Fatima it is
medically impossible for her to get
pregnant so how then did this happen
well the show has hinted at this town
possessing some sort of healing power in
season 1 Tabitha remarks that Ethan's
wound has healed insanely fast with
Ethan even saying about the town I know
it tries to hurt people
but maybe it tries to help people too
there's also Tilly who gave up her
painkillers but we aren't sure if that's
because Whatever She's suffering from is
in remission then there are small things
like Ellis up and about the very morning
after he was brutally stabbed and almost
died as Donna tries to stress to Fatima
we already know impossible things happen
in this town so is it not possible then
that some of these things might be good
at the end of the episode it looks as
though Fatima is ready to tell Ellis the
truth the biggest mystery this episode
is that of smiley and his corpse we saw
Boyd transfer his worm blood into him
which caused an adverse reaction that is
seemingly killed this monster so the
gang does what any rational person would
do and bring it inside to study now
there are a few interesting things to
note about this autopsy one the body
flinches when Christy cuts into it
however she explains that that could
have just been because she hit a nerve
two the body is devoid of any fluids
which is odd since Boyd had just
transferred those blood worms over where
did they go three the insides look like
those of a human although shriveled up
and for the gallbladder bile this is the
only fluid found which Boyd and Christy
will extract to likely test its effect
on other monsters essentially the
function of bile is to Aid in the
digestion and breakdown of fats in the
body so whether or not this has any
correlation to why it was found remains
to be seen and just a quick reminder if
you do like these videos please make
sure to like And subscribe every little
bit helps the channel out throughout the
past two episodes something has been on
elgin's mind he'll later tell Julie that
there's something about his dream that
he's supposed to remember in the events
of the past two days have only
strengthened this feeling it's almost as
though elgin's dream was a glimpse into
the future remember in episode 1 he told
the bus that they're not supposed to be
there so in order to get more clarity he
tries Julie's method of submerging
himself in a bath which ends with him
being hold under and the voice of a
woman or women screaming the sound is
oddly distorted and wobbly almost as if
it could be underwater a few episodes
ago Elgin also had a strange feeling
about the pond and I'm wondering if
there's a connection with drowning in
this place there's also the appearance
of the ballerina music box last episode
I theorized that this ballerina might be
guiding our characters maybe it's
wanting Elgin to go back to that pond
I'm now even thinking what would happen
if they put one of the monsters in that
water they have almost no liquids in
them it would be an interesting
experiment well Roland shows off his
fancy drone a present that was supposed
to be for his nephew when Jim sees this
it Sparks an idea why not take the
antenna from the RV and Jerry rig it to
the Drone to get a better signal it's
similar to his idea of the antenna on
top of colony house at the end of season
1. Roland is also his regular douchebag
self and I wonder if we'll get any more
backstory on why he acts this way
perhaps the biggest question mark
however is that if this place is indeed
some sort of experiment wouldn't it make
sense that some of the town's people are
in on it this could explain how the man
on the radio knew about Tabitha digging
underneath the house unfortunately we
don't get a lot of new info when it
comes to Victor and the trees we already
know from season one that according to
Victor the trees move which is why he
enlists the help of Ethan to record
their locations but something new has
been brewing something that has never
happened for at least as long as Victor
has been in town the seasons are
changing back in episode 5 and 6 both
Victor and Boyd commented on the leaves
changing and here we get confirmation
that the town up until now had been in a
Perpetual state of summer so something
is definitely changing whether or not
this is linked to Donna's plants dying
which she remarks the soil is now made
of poison remains to be seen But as Jim
theorizes someone wants them to be low
on food to increase the stress on the
town and its people Jade and Tabitha
form an unlikely friendship when the two
Bond over their Visions while Tabitha
sees ghost children Jade opens up and
discusses his visions of the Dead Armor
Man civil war soldier and Christopher so
he empathizes with Tabitha when she says
she's been seeing these dead kids but
it's when Jade hears about the tunnels
that he becomes intrigued I wouldn't be
surprised that his next stop is inside
those tunnels in search of Clues after
all Jade has seen visions of this
ventriloquist dummy and there just so
happens to be one in those tunnels and
Tabitha said she found Christopher's
symbol which Jade had been obsessing
over in those tunnels what will he find
in there and is it something good for
the town or not now it's time I turn it
over to you I want to hear your thoughts
and theories on what's going to happen
next in the comments below thanks for
watching please make sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
good stuff
foreign